هذا وقد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل اثنين
من قوات النخبه احدهما ضابط برتبه رائد
بكتبه الهندسه بلواء جولاني والاخر قائد
فريق برتبه نقيب في لواء جفعاتي الذي يصنف
انه من القوات الخاصه خلال المعارك في
شمال قطا غز بذلك اذا يرتفع العدد المعلن
رسميا لقتل الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدء
العمليه البريه في غزه الى
بين ضابط وجندي كما يرتفع العدد الاجمالي
المعلن لقتل الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي الى
5504 وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قواته عمقت
عملياتها العسكريه في مدينه خان يونس وان
اللواء السابع مدرعات تمكن من الوصول الى
مقرات تابعه لحركه حماس بما فيها مداهمه
ما قال انه مقر الاستخبارات العسكريه
واضاف الجيش انه عثر على وثائق قال انها
على قدر من الاهميه وتشارك سبعه الويه
تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي في العمليات
العسكريه في خان يونس من بينها لواء كفير
وهو اكبر الالويه في القوات البريه لجيش
الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
الاسرائيلي